see what I mean man do you see what I
mean that fight in episode 2 and as I
was watching I'll say to myself you know
it's a good episode but uh yeah a lot of
talking and I says a little fighting or
something at last three minutes she'll
be the floor suit do you see do you see
well here well we'll get to that in a
second IV that whole thing d'azyr's be
talked about but um yeah you know let's
so let's talk about this first of all um
I really loved how the last episode ends
with this big montage going on and you
know he hears a kid crying he's like
yeah pulls down the mask
let's go hands up in a dumpster all
right we're gonna see something like I
thought you would dump into basically
something like you would see at the end
of this episode where it's the gasket
gives me instead yeah after all he just
wakes up in a dumpster goes like oh well
I guess he didn't save the kid later but
you know the more and more I'm seeing
this you know at least with these first
two episodes I'm a necessarily a judge
but I'm servicing the restrictions of a
TV show because clearly even the first
episode yeah there's one or two fight
scenes but there's not that many for you
comic book the action show uh but kind
of like an anime they use it very
smartly like a really smart anime even
if it doesn't have a ton of money behind
it in its budget will do so well to get
a really stylized shot but you have like
a close-up of the eyes or something like
that and you won't see the mouth movie
because that cost money
so but they'll do a very stylized and
that's one thing with this show it
doesn't look like it has a ton of money
but with what they do
they use it in all the right spots where
they have obviously not a ton of lights
but they put in the right spot so you
get some nice shadows and something that
they don't have a ton of lights I just
don't think they have a lot of sets that
are that interesting so stylist kids
like to use well maybe shoot in the dark
we know bring about lighting happy and
you know indeed
good actors to make this stuff work and
then yeah when you do the fight scenes
that you just put so much into these
sort of small snippets of fights but are
so effectively done and clear I need
this episode very little violence really
until the end
um one time by the interrogation torture
see yeah so you got um
rosario Dawson who's you know wait I
thought I was Rosie Perez oh shut the
fuck up when she came on is that mostly
Perez I got the names mixed up man I
just got a look at Doug like this they
clearly the actresses clearly had
nothing but I'm sorry Dawson who I you
know I haven't seen turn in like a bad
performance ever but I'd never seen like
a holy shit that was like really fucking
good performance and in this like even
though it's not like you know the
media's role I feel like she kind of
made something of it you know what she's
like
look I want to get behind you I want to
believe you but you're a weirdo yeah but
you gotta give me some proof that you're
worth following and what she said I'm
like I really fucking believe her and I
like really I like the slippery slope
that claire has of I don't want to make
of all this I don't want some guy doing
on the on my carpet and all of this and
then finally I think it's the reveal of
when these is you know where's the kid
the kids already did we're gonna do good
and we just sell him like other the more
he talks the more you can almost see the
wheels in her brain turning and she's
like alright this guy really needs to go
down lengua and that's when she's like
daredevil trigeminal nerve I think
there's a sense to that like I don't
know they didn't give her way her
backstory anything I don't recall but
you kind of get the feeling like she's
been through some shit yeah when she
sees like this guy you know that maybe
she's seen a bunch of these guys do this
kind of stuff you know not handing it
they were it's like you know okay dick
I'm gonna help out with ya right here
this conversation I was having with a
relative we were talking about that she
might be night nurse or one of the night
nurses which was a group of nurses who
helped tend to superheroes but the names
different like there were like I know
two or three of them are something one
of them was actually named Lynda Carter
which is the only one I remember because
of that was hilarious at you name when
the Carter but I it's not Claire what's
a Claire Claire yeah so I I don't know I
would have guessed it's actually
nightmares I don't know where they're
going with this or if they're just
screwin us around and they're like
that's gonna be nice oh but that that's
a possibility that I think is on the
table
well and me some similarities so you
have this back this back story that
again I because I saw the movie I know
what's gonna happen to the father I know
how it's gonna happen all that stuff my
god
I didn't want it to happen I
legitimately read even by wrapped up I
lit totally even though I see it in a
million movies before I totally bought
the relationship between him and his son
and it felt legit and this episode even
though and it's hard on and I we were
talking about how we feel sorry for this
kid actor because it's a tough thankless
role to constantly kind of be in the
position to cry and you're screaming
you're crying holes it off yeah in such
a way that I'm like in a lesser movie in
the daredevil movie like for instance it
doesn't work but here this kid and this
actor playing his father really like I
buy the camaraderie they have and this
will be you'll find out later why this
is so important because it's gonna
juxtapose this with other characters
well I'll say this to the defense of the
daredevil movie this has an entire
episode to death ya know it has way more
time but but yeah it's well like what
you were saying I mean we've seen this a
million times a million movies you know
yeah I'm gonna
when that fight you're gonna see
everything's gonna be fine gosh damn
it's gonna be I mean we've seen this
like a million times but by God like you
see him when you see him going into the
ring and getting ready to go I'm just
like I don't want him to die I do not
what this guy who died when he turns I
hear some Chinese name any closest I'll
see ya I mean I'll say he enters the
ring the way it built it up with the
music and he's got the sort of the boxer
sort of show or his head it's almost
like a holy moment like the mystical
scene out of a Cathedral like you know
it ah it's such a great scene ya know it
was everything effectively done and I
forget like in the daredevil movie he
didn't cash out his money and leave it
to his kid right not in the cut that we
side yeah like that makes a huge
difference because it's a self-sacrifice
and I mean he's doing it for
self-respect and to show his kid that he
can win ya know cuz that's nice but it's
more than that more more like I think he
knows he's gonna there's a good chance
he's not gonna make it out of this if he
does this and so he's like well I also
gave it to my dear my son yeah I think
he feels almost a sense of uselessness
hmm like there's something to that
character and of course is this whole
Catholic sense of guilt and sacrifice it
was a great line to know about any one
of a punishment and somebody who just
constantly takes punishment without ever
complaining is like what about last
rites just being careful yeah but yeah
there seems to be this sense of
self-sacrifice and like finding use for
yourself and I always get the feeling
that the father feels like he's not
smart he says he was never good at
school you know his only way to provide
is to kind of lose fights like and I
think he saw this as a way like I'm
gonna win back the self-respect to my
son and provide for him for the rest of
his life with this money yeah well I I
think that gets to this episode
particularly seems to get to what I what
I'm seeing is the strength of this show
which a lot of the movies either don't
do because they feel is that important
or don't do cuz they don't have time
which it allows these moments for these
characters just be moments as the big
TVs you can have time for this and I'm
thinking even like the Karen and uh
foggy just going out and getting drunk
IB it's like but is it really one that
mythical ile trick hey what's this oh
shit um but even then it's like there's
not a ton of exposition going on it's
just a lot of character building and I
legitimately like watching them it makes
me realize you know what off steam its
then I like that you can get away that
much more in a TV show I mean you can
with a movie it makes me realize as much
as I have enjoyed I enjoyed the Avengers
I the the chunks of the spider-man films
I enjoyed Iron Man and you know the big
Marvel movie said of course the Dark
Knight and the original Batman and
Superman zai I this may be a brave new
world here because I would actually much
rather watch a thousand shows like this
taking a comic book and turning it into
this then I would probably going and
seeing another comic book movie like
I'll go see comic book movies and I'll
have a good time but I'll be thinking of
this oh my hey I'll be my kind of like
oh man I wish I could all just be like a
13 episode series like daredevil because
like it really kind of nails it well I'm
not gonna lie and I think I don't know
this is too it's I think it's more to
its benefit but I don't even really see
it as like a comic book show I don't see
it as this fascinating you know I see it
about a drama you know what I said you
auntie I will say this it I would say
it's a comic book show but much more
along the lines of that difference
between comic books and graphic novels
it is a graphic novel show like it right
down to the way it's shot in the use of
color and it looks like a gritty graphic
now yeah but that still is like in a way
an offshoot of like comic book and so it
still is that feeling to me but I I
think I know what you're saying it's
it's not spider-man running around in
spandex and bright and goofy and fun
even know even with like that it's dark
night I mean it's still a superhero
going around being a superhero
Smokey's low tech he's low tech and low
keys he has some superpowers but he's
really just some guy in a black mass and
the nice find it or the crime fighting
is not the focus win Jim like I said and
I'm not saying that's bad it's it's an
interesting take because that usually is
the fight that's what you don't deceive
when you see a comic-book shower well
late I was joking online that the funny
thing about this show because I also
have seen a few episodes of the flash
which i think is also really awesome so
both DC and Marvel are on their game
like but the funny thing is when I was
watching and then some of it is the
nature of the character of the flash and
daredevil some say Daredevils Marvel's
answer to Batman and way to a certain
degree but like when I watch the way
each show is set up it makes me laugh
because I'm like Marvel has given me the
Batman I've kind of always want it at
least out of like the films like both
the nola member and the burden I do like
the burden fills of them but I feel like
some of this is closer to the batman the
dark gritty old school 30's and more
batman you know like yeah and the flash
meanwhile is kind of giving me the
spider-man I always wanted and they're
both the opposite companies doing it
it's Marvel's daredevil in DC's the
flash but I'm like DC's giving me a
better spider-man on the ones I think
with the flash I Marvel's giving me the
better Batman you know with this it's
just kind of funny but hey more power to
them like I'm glad that both of them are
turning out really good products in TV
even if it's a bizarro world the one
thing well well principal were you're
talking about the graphic novel and
stuff like that and whether or not it's
kind of a comic book show um after this
episode I mean can you see like that
line about the Avengers it yeah they
punch him through building it's any kid
I can't connect this world to Avengers
I just can't um you know I love it I
think it's great but I'm looking at this
like no no this was not the same place
where Loki came through
you know the whole token mismanage I'm
like this is a totally different
creature so I do think it's a little odd
that it's supposed to take place in that
same admire man that's not to say those
movies can't have dark moments but
honestly I can see it I the problem is
the styles of the filmmaking are so
different the Avengers is definitely
very don't argue a little bit of the
tone I mean do we need and they can be
no thank you yes of dark tones but I
mean this is like like I'm gonna tone
the tone of this is dark but this is
also how you put this like the Avengers
I don't want to say adventures versus
agents of shield because I've never
wasn't a giant fan of early agents of
shield but this is kind of like the
Avengers level heroes versus I mean
daredevil he's Murdock's working from
the ground up he's literally the pond
scum on the bottom like working in the
pond scum on the bottom here compared
with the Avengers who are fighting the
gods and this and that like he's just
fighting criminal scum I guess I kind of
like it's kind of like let's say the
Keaton Batman the Chris or range
Superman we girls have the power the new
power those connected and they mentioned
like metropolis once or twice and it's
like well I just can't it's like he kind
of just got to accept it like in this
universe apparently there is a room for
a Gotham and metropolis yeah I guess I
wasn't sitting on like a huge major
problem but it is you know tone wise
it's like there's a little eye lens a
little jarring oh it isn't it is totally
different like but in the same way I
love Avengers for the lightheartedness
and goofiness god I love this this like
that you know the what the one thing I
have to be honest I didn't know about I
you know it's one thing to get punched a
guy and he and I do we seen the hero is
like whatever do bad things to bad guys
and stuff like that there really is
something about taking that knife and
putting it whatever above is our our
high whatever that was right Jim another
I mean I was just like oh I mean I and
I'm sure they'll give like whatever a
reason why he does ban like even more
and just more of a backstory yet but I
was telling into the philosophy but I
mean I think you've what you saw is what
you got he's like I want to find out
where this kid is and I'm going to
torture this cat
yeah I'm not sitting him right that's
saying I don't know about that's the one
Sierra's like I don't know did that did
that maybe go too far I'm not sure
pushes him off you know what and like I
can't explain what even that I predict
that like and push them any pushes them
you know I mean dad was the guy
ultimately was always eat ourself but
you know there's some but I mean that is
like very old-school Batman dark like
care of this guys really know there's a
it's like I've seen Batman punch people
that's I've even seen fucking carry a
gun if I'd never seen kinda guy like
original original Batman we're like he
really was like a crazed freakin
vigilante who was you know like one step
removed from a fashions is a I'm a
fuckin do it I want like that early like
first year kind of Batman like I'm not
talking about the Nolan Batman who's
like well drop a guy from one story and
if he breaks his ankles oh well you know
you know they're about the bad man that
killed people
you know today and again this could be
playing to its strengths not really its
weakness is that that character is so
again is so charming and likable and and
you know seems so caring and loving you
want to be with this guy the way does
something like that it is really jarring
but you could mix ever do it oh that's
yeah that's the duality of the character
sides he's Catholic he can go confess
and tell himself often there's something
I don't know like I said when you bring
a knife in I don't know why that seems
like a point where it's like that just
gets like boogy little Tuesday this is
mine who gave him the advice oh she's
breathing Oersted which I thought was
badass - it's like I'm gonna use my
medical advice to hurt somebody I
thought was mad like he was gonna scare
with that in a break but no he like you
fucking got - that is a clear violation
of her oh if you know above all else
dunno Harmon and stabbed him right above
the eye there but I mean but yeah but
again you could see how they got there
he keeps trying and he's getting nothing
and you could see almost feel her
disgust and reaction at what he's saying
like a novel selva kid I will kill the
kid who care
like this event and finally she like you
know I'm gonna do it this kid's gonna
die if we don't get this information
like she goes through the same process
in her own head and yeah I mean don't
get me wrong that's a if there is a
reason to do that I mean that that's a
legit reason um but it's I don't know
maybe it's just like a weird night thing
I am but I really thought that might
have been pushing it a little bit and
totally no no no when I saw it I
flinched like I was like oh I saw the
kids stitching up his father yeah I
don't that didn't bother me at all but
that seemed like the performance helps
too because that guy is like giving it
as on yeah so so so I don't know I'm not
claiming it why does that work and not
you know whatever Batman breaking a
guy's ankles weight throws him off a
building Roy's everything I don't know
but it is something where it's like I'd
be like I don't know it works really
works in Dark Knight I just feel that
it's always glossed over though like any
breaks guys ankles then gets in rigid
boom like watch said like I
there's no dwelling on it like this one
just dwells on it like oh no we're not
gonna shy away from this this is just
gonna be a quick like you're gonna see
what this guy is gonna do to get what he
wants but uh but again when you go from
something like that where the violence
is very you know pretty gruesome I mean
even as my super gory it's pretty
gruesome uh
to that fight at the end where it's like
yeah you see them sort of do these flips
and jump off the stuff but it all looks
doable it does not look too comic book
ish and it's still like I said it sounds
like it's really really hitting each
other and okay yeah let's talk about
that fight scene because this is one of
the few fights and I love it this is
another thing I realized they're really
missing in some of these action films
they are missing the tired they're
missing the brunette's what makes that
see the also scenes where daredevil kind
of social apps and the other guys are
just like there's a wonderful scene but
they all get up almost I will taste like
yeah all right all right give it okay
and you could see you could see Murdock
kind of following their lead almost like
I'm gonna get up first you get up feel
like they're all like waiting for each
other to get up
wait because if I are waiting to see if
I was gonna well yeah cuz I give I give
it's that bit I don't want to say
laziness with just that I'm in the
middle of a fighting like I'm tired like
if I could get another second or two to
relax yeah Jason yeah but they're all
taking that and slowly getting up like
like you get a prisoner you go to prison
all right we're gonna guess we're doing
this again like it odds oh you know area
you see them all really straight dare
double you know the whole episode is
dedicated to describing his wounds so
what he goes in there he's really good
you know exactly where and how he's
speaking of knowing the setup for that
whole scene of taking the one camera and
there's a number of tricks there's no
way it's always yeah always
yeah going but taking that one shot
suppose what's supposed to look like one
shot and going through and giving you
the entire layout how many guys how many
guys where the kid is you know where
these guys are going and how its set up
and then flipping around to show you
where Daredevils coming in from and then
flipping around again so it's like you
know the geography and then just letting
the camera sit still and only moving
slightly during a few scenes and just
letting the fun fall so here's the one
thing I just now realized okay so I'm
assuming there was a guard or a couple
guys or something at the front door
because why would he just walk it makes
it so you assume he took those guys up
alright so he took those guys and those
guys would have phoned or something and
he obviously took him out and they
didn't know they'd go in their rooms
what's the stuff daredevil he goes in he
hears these guys in these rooms and they
he just waits to say he knows been that
coming out of something's just like okay
he just goes through the kid grabs the
key run fight those two rooms and guys
well what if the one of a got out of a
game to the kid or song or something
yeah well I didn't he's gonna start
carry a kid out and if one of the guards
seize this unfolding is that one there
this is what Jesus
you can't say - if you get caught number
of the kids he is cornered if he can
that he has no wiggle room well I think
he thought - that he can get the jump on
them and Surprise them and he kind of
did yeah
I don't see all the tussock TV I wanted
them that was later the TV that that's
but yeah guy looks over balls down but
you know it's up the importance and
really any of the importance of showing
what a character is tired and drained
and everybody is and stuff is it shows
the strength of the hero
it shows the strength of okay he's
really targets really hurt but you know
he's gonna get up and keep going
not only that but one of the things I
love about this show him keep coming
back this is just a position of showing
one side versus another and how they
affect each other and in this case it's
showing his whole back story in his
connection with his father is what
almost kind of informs everything he's
doing in the present was saving this kid
like you could feel the loss of his
father and you can tell that there was
something about this abduction because
he's chasing after this kid since the
end of episode one there was something
about this abduction in particular in
bed it really is getting to him that's
gay he doesn't know the guy any other is
how long yeah I know the kid yeah it's
bugging him on a deep personal level
like he took this one personally and I
think it's that in the way that his
final words to his dad were daddy daddy
and the way it keeps cutting back to the
other kid who also says daddy they're
like juxtaposing these two things like
it reminds him of something of that that
he's lost and therefore he's like I'm
gonna fix this you know and it's
something the show does like the whole
way through things that happen in the
past inform the present and I just loved
it like it worked well in this episode
it worked well and well that was some
things in the last episode I forgot to
mention when you know he's down on the
ground is daredevil he's beat up
instantly this guy's coming to kill him
or whatever and he Katie we cut to that
flashback and just Wayne says I mean
does he directly I don't even know if it
those directly impacted but just Wayne
says now get to work and he steps up
it's like yeah I don't know like that
really connected even if I don't even
know the whole side have to say again
but it the whole scene I'm gonna
flashback it's just insane now get to
work with him standing up it's
how many times have we seen comic book
movies where there's flashbacks that
they just feel arbitrarily and there's a
flashback just to have a flashback like
they don't really connect to anything
like I don't want them to connect
somehow to the rest of the movie but it
just feels like oh we wanted to give
some character development we don't know
where to fit it so just throw it here
another great edit that edge again and
just that that triggered a flashback is
when he says there's a guy going door to
door II is this really strong cologne
he's gonna come to the door there's some
things you don't know about me blah blah
blah and then you hear boom boom boom
and turns out it's the punching I was
like yeah oh ffs the knocking at the
door it is the knocking at the door as
well cos when it comes back they're
answering the door you know NYPD come on
open up so it's like that triggered the
the flashback you know and as well as
everything that's going on with the kid
or reminds him back of his you know
childhood and everything so there is a
connection and yeah I think the last
thing I probably have on this is again
just going back to the characters when
they you show how strong they are in
their weakest moments and that includes
physically I think I'm sure there's are
movies where I've seen it but the the
two that jump out the most to me is a is
actually Batman which I know is kind of
weird but when he's getting his ass
kicked by that guy before he goes after
the Joker it's just sort of you know
he's widget initely having troubles
getting blood out I just Marisa kid I'm
like what Batman can't leave we've got
no get Batman fight back but back and I
just got so invested because I always
like a bit to where he comes on the
batplane after it's a story and blows
the smoke and yeah like that to it
who me you know that there's something
about like you know you get much more
invested when it kind of looks like what
they can lose and they can lose it away
you can quickly understand and the first
one that always jumps in my head and I
think the movies really applying for
that wasn't race a lost art but got when
Harrison Ford is fighting oh yeah I mean
and like it always looks like he's on
the cusp of losing like he always just
barely scrapes up yeah and he was a fun
hire that you know when in most but the
Talmud the German pilot he's like
alright
evolve guy come here come here and just
and she still takes him out but not my
favorite I mean is when he gets shot in
the arm in Varese a lost art and the the
one that not succeed and he punches him
in the eye oh my god yeah he is ji me he
didn't go after any punches what I mean
like that so you fucking feel that her
and then you admire him even more when
he can come out of it he can pull it
together every blows you really do and
that is so rare and it's you know on the
one hand it's kind of cringe where they
could try oh oh but you're so invested
you peel send it go when he gets him
back it's something I didn't feel I
didn't feel within Man of Steel I don't
really feel within Avengers and most is
the Spider Man's most comic book movies
I don't feel any of the blows and like
I'm sure some of that some purpose cuz
they're meant to be fade yeah man there
they're showing the stunts in the cop
but you were nice to finally get one
like that's dark and gritty enough to be
like now you're gonna feel every frickin
saw my flesh against bone and you know
ya know it's nice to play splattered
everywhere it's nice to be reminded that
this stuff I mean there's a reason we
find this stuff exciting is that if it
did have been real life it would be
really really you know well there's
think it makes sense to because in
basically at its core it's about boxing
yeah well there was a I'm forgetting the
name of the knob there's a Kevin Costner
movie where he said you know whenever
somebody Western II so where he shot it
when something would shoot a gun you
want people to react like somebody shot
a gun five 10 to you no no no it was a
it was a Western and she wasn't that
good but it looked gorgeous
uh I'm trying to like open West or
something like that
oh I don't talking about I know actually
exact and I wasn't terrible but wasn't
that great but but every time somebody
fired a gun the room would go quiet and
the gunshot echoed you know and it's
like everyone it's like you felt like
holy shit somebody just took exactly
what this is a machine that can protect
a small little bullet across so fast it
can go through you and kill you and it
lets out a sound like thunder and every
time it happened you felt it and the
room went quiet and it just said chills
every time it's the same thing here what
somebody is
punished you hear that sound and you
feel it and it just feels so legit and
it just gets you so much more best
another good one actually you just
flashed to it is uh that did something
similar hunt for in October when he
blows the KGB agent at the end there's
like this kind of gust of wind s in and
just yeah right amount of slow-mo that
every impact you kind of feel like it
just it just resonates and yeah I don't
I don't see that no I and I get what I'm
saying that I shouldn't even say comic
movies is if it's only been generations
and that's like where the old 80s films
like sorry Millennials were old but
that's where I think the 80s films like
and the 70s films like really nailed it
like somehow we sanitized it like
violence has to be sanitized down you
watch those 80 films it's like you feel
the violence like it it feels like a
punch in the gut whereas pg-13 films
nowadays it just it's to clean than one
oh baby but here's the thing I know why
we did that and I'm not entirely against
it because just punching people get
boring and now we want to do we got the
the matrix and the crouching perineum
and we got the martial arts which is
beautiful and incredible and you know
amazing to see so that it would suddenly
became much more showy and flashy and
for comic book movies that's great for
action films that's great but yes we
started to lose the actual investment of
when somebody punches someone it hurts
you know and it's gonna hurt like it
should properly hurt and that sucks you
win once again to the reality of the
situation it doesn't to be real but you
have to have a reality to that
environment and I think it's actually
when much more when you feel every
single hit that's done so this is a good
combination that there are stunts there
is plebeian jumping off the walls and
stuff throwing TVs and everything but
you still feel the impact every single
time and it's a really good Sarah man if
you hit the trigeminal there yes I just
want to talk one more time just again
about the use of color and darkness and
shadow in every episode the predominant
color seems to be yellow in orange and I
love it
there in Hell's Kitchen and the whole
thing is lit like it's fucking L yeah
the bar has deep reds the exteriors when
they're on the roof are oranges the
interior the apartments are yellow like
and any time you're looking out the
windows from their office or from
Claire's apartment yeah it's always this
deep orange yellow like they're in a
constant purgatory there is something
and yellows not an easy color to make
look interesting and they really do it
well in this show well in waves going
down that alleyway Ahmet that long shot
the action scene um you know I was
really impressed by how one room is
yellow another room is green another
room is red you know I was just missing
a blue now it's the one thing my OCD is
like I've got a blue uh but ton of blue
if I'm remembering the show right I
don't think the blue eye seems to be
during the day yeah during the day
there's sometimes some night chef
fluorescent light or no deep blue
no but that's hard to do that's hard to
get different colors in each room you
have to purposefully like really go out
your way to do that because you you know
be a change but this is a
cinematographer and the the director
photography the lighting guys I it's
just such an incredible job they're just
scenes where Rosario Dawson's just her
face is just lit with a faint of orange
and it's just her against black it's
just a dark set behind her and it looks
like a Rembrandt painting like it looks
like somebody painted it or drew it
right yeah not like our crappy lighting
cos but um you know something you nail
we were talking about sort of these
grainy looking movies I mean even
something like the New Avengers that you
know really guys looks um their service
they're upping the exposure and the
graininess to apparently make it darker
and as the avengers this is the best
example but you know by like Man of
Steel we picked idol line so I don't
wanna bring that up but but sort of
stuff a lot of people are doing in
I think so it just it's the easy recent
target I'm trying to think of a bigger
movie that did it but but something that
no but there are other films that do
this yeah a lot of films it's not just
Man of Steel just because we're talking
about comic books so it springs to mind
esta lean yeah
so that the shadows in this and the
black and the lightness too are very
clear they're not grainy you can clearly
mark out where the outline is and where
the light source is coming from it's
Cuffy you don't see them probably like
what you're seeing now because our live
shows there's a respect for shadows too
which is something like I think people
think that like to do a black and white
film would be really easy that somehow
is it oh yeah yeah yeah well you just
suck the color out of it and you turn it
gray and I know all you've done is
turned to gray like just taking
something and making it black and white
is not the same as shooting something as
if it were meant to be in black and
white and this is shot almost like a
black and white film like it is
basically light dark and the use of
shadows in this is just amazing this is
what sets this apart from other comic
book films that try to be gritty by well
it's gonna be all grain is in the old
dark colors and but instead there's no
differentiation between the light and
the darkness the shadow the foreground
the background and you just end up with
just something that just looks like a
flat gray mess why there's everything's
great whereas this it is just as dark as
night versus something in the foreground
which has a brightness to it you know
versus other scenes I see in other
movies where it's just like oh here's a
scene in a room at night but
everything's just kind of lit the same
there's no real shadows there's no but
it's gray or blue or green tinted
therefore it's start that no well I
think nailed it with you know it's not
black and white it's gray you know just
because you suck out the color have you
ever to actually tried to make something
black and white like solid black and
solid white on film
it is trickier than it looks but it is
gorgeous when you get it right so I
think you're right I think that by
sucking out the color they think they
give like a white but they don't they
get very
gray you know sometimes you get black
sometimes you get a white but to have
something mostly black and white is very
tricky and takes great craftsmanship to
do if you look at old 60s horror films
like the innocence or the haunting or
even some of the classic universal stuff
like and look at how they're filmed this
is how it's done
or even since any honest yeah or even
could it actually since it he's a good
example and this reminds me of Sin City
that's how it's done like that's how you
accomplish that effect and they're doing
it with color and it's gorgeous and I
wish more movies would do it like this
because you can have a movie that has
deep rich saturated colors a lot of the
colors in this it's a nutty saturated
there some of these are rich yellows
rich Reds and rich but it still feels
dark and gritty as fuck it reminds me a
lot of the only other film it might be
the still its own unique thing but Dick
Tracy it's where I did this very extreme
color but this extreme dark shadows you
know and you can clearly you know
outline the shadow very clearly it
wasn't you want to show you how to bring
a graphic novel to life watch this show
and take notes here in film school take
notes yeah so yeah going episode 2 can't
wait for 30 oh it gets good so we'll see
you there